the Joe Rogan experience like this Greta
thern burn girl do they have to go to
her every time anybody says anything
wrong about the climate because
apparently meatloaf said something would
it mean leave say something about her
specifically I think he said did he yeah
oh I thought he had a claw I wrote the
headline I read and I'm a [ __ ] sucker
for clickbait has said he had climate
denial comments yeah he just said
something like relax he pretty much like
kind of did that that passive-aggressive
thing like chill out lady
it's probably being funny yeah that's
what we do
he took well I did feel kind of bad for
it I think it's hilarious that like
imagine all the other girls in school
what did they think about her you know
like I have a friend who worked with
autistic people and she said she thinks
she's autistic she she thinks that this
situation is like a really bright child
that maybe is being like pushed in this
direction to be this public figure
it's just her it's not that her opinions
aren't valid they definitely are valid
but it's just it's not healthy to take a
young kid who's developing and then
thrust them into the front of something
like global climate change debate it's
so hostile and then just instantaneously
this kid is getting mocked and [ __ ] with
and then they're asking her to make
statements and and how dare you that how
dare you just plays over and over and
over again like she's not wrong it's not
wrong her opinions but it's like she's
really young to handle this I don't know
if she's autistic she seems very very
smart issues like this all day
that's good question is like when you
think of autism don't you like almost
immediately think they're probably
really smart at something oh yeah so
that's from brain man or is that
accurate
no that's accurate that's why the
government uses them to for their
military for like radars and stuff
because they're very smart at one
certain thing or a few certain things
you know inaccuracy is another one that
I think a lot of them are smart I do one
time when I was really high I had a
crazy thought about autism and that all
these spectrum disorders are eventually
going to make emotions
like a less significant aspect of being
a human being you know some people some
people they don't have any control over
their emotions right there just did they
fly off the handle they're nutty they
cry they scream it's Very's right with
all of us we didn't be like more
efficient if that wasn't the case
anymore
like if it was a like like an appendix
you know we had an appendix we had a
organ that we used to use to prot was it
like processing roots and [ __ ] or bark
bone was it bone yeah I thought it was
like breaking down bones something we
don't use anymore
because of our diet change like imagine
if your emotions become something like
that like some people have emotional
flare-ups like other guy blew out his
appendix they just had a [ __ ] hissy
fit at his brother's wedding [ __ ] no
[ __ ] you man
dad always [ __ ] said which one of the
pillows is an extra prozac makes you
just numb to like thoughts is an accent
yeah I think xanax is the anti relax
that one prozac's of speed right or
anti-anxiety one xanax isn't anxiety
think so yeah it's like just peers
headaches all the time like somebody
told me that we take that when you get
off of it it accentuates the anxiety
like once you get off this little rubber
band effect but then a doctor told me
that's horseshit
[Applause]